حاول أن تستوعب هذا الأمر، حيث تم
احتجاز رجل يبلغ من العمر 26 عامًا في بيرو بعد أن
عثرت الشرطة على مومياء يصل عمرها إلى 800 عام
في حقيبة تبريد لتوصيل الطعام،
قال الرجل إنه أطلق عليها اسم المومياء خوانيتا،
وقال إنها صديقته الروحية
لشبكة سي إن إن.  ينضم إلينا توم فورمان الآن، العديد من
الأسئلة، توم، العديد من الأسئلة حول
هذه القصة، لكن لنبدأ بكيفية
اكتشاف الشرطة البيروفية للمومياء
جيدًا، ويبدو أن هذا الرجل واثنين من
أصدقائه كانوا في حالة سكر،
وكانوا بالقرب من موقع أثري حيث
كانوا في حالة سكر أو  لا نعرف ولكن
بعد ذلك ذهبوا وكان لديهم
حقيبة توصيل كبيرة يستخدمها تطبيق توصيل الطعام
هناك ثم نظرت السلطات إلى
الداخل ووجدت هذه المومياء بالداخل
وهي
ملفوفة من الرأس إلى أخمص القدمين بشكل أساسي في
نوع فضفاض  من أغلفة القماش
الشائعة جدًا بالنسبة للمومياوات التي يتم العثور عليها في
ذلك البلد ليتم تحضيرها بهذه الطريقة،
وقال هذا الرجل أوه، لقد امتلكت هذا
لفترة من الوقت وأحتفظ بها معي وهي اه
دعونا نرى يقول إنه ينام معها وهو
يتسكع في الجوار  معه طوال الوقت الذي كانت فيه
في غرفتي، أخبر وكالة أنباء أخرى
أن والده كان لديه هذه المومياء في الأصل، وأنه
بطريقة ما جاء إليها
هنا، ومع ذلك فإن السلطات لست
متأكدة من أنهم يشترون أيًا من هذا، لذا فقد
حصلوا على هذا  اه هذه المومياء
وأخذوا هذا الرجل إلى الحجز لمزيد من
الاستجواب لبريانا، نعم لأن هناك الكثير من
الأسئلة ولذلك أطلق على هذه المومياء اسم
خوانيتا، وهذا في الواقع تعلموا أن
مومياء رجل فماذا يحدث
لخوانيتا أم يجب أن نقول خوان الآن؟
أعتقد أن خوان سيكون خيارًا جيدًا،
حسنًا، من الواضح أن السلطات هناك قد
أخذته بين
أيديهم باعتباره قطعة أثرية رائعة وهذا
شيء يجب النظر إليه لأنه ضع
في اعتبارك أنني أريدك أن تفكر في
عمر هذا وهو 800 عام  كان جنكيز خان البالغ من العمر 800
عام لا يزال يجوب
الأرض في الوقت الذي كانت فيه الحروب الصليبية
لا تزال جارية، وهذا قبل أن
يبدأ الغزاة بالفعل في
النزول إلى أمريكا الجنوبية بشكل عام،
لذا فهو وقت مهم حقًا في
تاريخ البلاد بالنسبة لهم للدراسة.
في قطعة أثرية حقيقية ذات قيمة كبيرة بالنسبة
لهم هناك ولكن هنا هذا الرجل
مجرد نوع من الاستعراض مع هذا
الشيء، لقد حدث هذا النوع من الأشياء
قبل أن تعرف بريانا
ونهب القطع الأثرية إذا كانت هذه هي
الطريقة التي تم بها كل هذا في الواقع  يحدث نهب القطع
الأثرية من جميع أنحاء العالم
طوال الوقت، وفي بعض الأحيان يكون الأمر
كذلك، حيث يتمكن شخص ما من الوصول إلى
واحدة لسبب ما، ويحزمونها
ويحملونها بعيدًا، ثم
ينتهي الأمر ببيعها في مكان ما، ومن
المثير للاهتمام أن تلك المومياوات  من مصر
ومن أماكن أخرى كانت ذات
قيمة كبيرة وتم تداولها في الكثير
من الأماكن، وكانت الحالة هنا
لا نعرف ما نعرفه هو أنها
قصة غريبة على غير العادة رواها هذا الرجل
لمحاولة تبرير ما يحدث  معه
ومع هذه الأصول الثقافية الوطنية
التي عادت الآن إلى
الأيدي المناسبة، نأمل أن تكون القصة الأكثر غرابة لهذا اليوم
كلها لك توم فورمان، شكرًا جزيلاً لك وهذا ما ساعدني،
شكرًا
لانضمامك إلينا، لا تذهب إلى أي مكان
بعد  لا يزال لدينا المزيد من الأخبار في المستقبل